good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2021-2022
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence and biomedicine where we
enjoy presentations on fridays from
leading thinkers with about the promise
opportunities and hurdles which are
associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected
participants in our biomedical data
science innovation lab program will have
will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating
in-person grant project development
workshop to be held here in historic
charlottesville virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data
science innovation lab program are being
accepted until january 31st 2022 so
please consider applying or encouraging
your junior colleagues to do so we will
look forward to reviewing their
materials today it is my honor and my
privilege to welcome our speaker dr
jarrett zagan from the university of
virginia
dr ziegan is the porterfield chair of
bioethics and professor of anthropology
here at uva he is the former founding
director of the center for data ethics
and justice at uva he received his ma in
liberal arts from saint john's college
and a phd in anthropology from the city
university of new york he subsequently
was a member of the institute for
advanced study at princeton university a
visiting scholar at columbia university
and a research fellow at the max planck
institute for social anthropology
excuse me his lab has been funded
through a fulbright hayes fellowship and
netherlands organization for scientific
research award and the european research
council among many other sources
his interests include ethical theory
problematics of being human the
political ontological uh oncological
relationality and thinking anthropo
anthropologically
about things in philosophy these
interests are explored in his most
recent book disappointment towards a
critical
hermen
hermeneutics of world building and a war
on people drug user policy and a new
ethics of community in continuing this
year's theme on biomedical data science
uh dr uh
zingan's lecture today is entitled on
the necessity of relational ethics and
empathic attunement for data centric
technologies in his talk he will make a
critical phenomenological response to
the ethical demand that ai be sensitive
to its varied sources of bias by arguing
for what he terms as relational ethics
in contrast to the dominant data ethical
arguments that call for the delineation
of principles or rules he will argue
that only data centric technologies are
capable of empathic attunement which can
legitimately be called ethical machines
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching on youtube thank you so
much for joining us today also our
specially selected 2021-2012
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are strongly encouraged to
submit any questions for jarrett via the
chat feature in their zoom sessions i
will synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome jared we are super excited
to hear from you today
thank you jack
it's a real pleasure to be here
i'd like to talk today about ethics and
data-centric technologies but before i
do i just wanted to offer a bit of a
warning
i'm not a data scientist nor an engineer
i don't code
and honestly i more or less use my
computer as little more than a very
fancy typewriter
i am going to be frank
simply a theorist
who on occasion humbly attempts to think
about our contemporary condition of
existence and how we try to live within
it so my talk today will be a
theoretical intervention in the emerging
ethical concerns around data-centric
technologies
put simply this is a theory paper i will
leave the practice to those who are able
to do that and hope that they are
inspired in their work in what i say
here today
most of my talk is extracted from an
article called can machines be ethical
that i published about a year ago in the
journal social research so you're
welcome to go to that journal and and
have a look
to begin today
though i will briefly make some
superficial distinctions of how ethics
is generally talked about in relation to
data centric practices and technologies
then i will continue by clarifying what
i mean by ethics as relational ethics
and finally i will provide an example
that i hope illustrates that relational
ethics more appropriately responds to
the ethical concerns many have today
about data centric technologies and my
less than hopeful outlook on the
possibility of its implementation
so let's get started
ethics is a growing concern in the realm
of data sciences artificial intelligence
and data centric technologies in general
there are good reasons for this
we are all familiar with concerns over
such issues as data privacy or
data-driven surveillance or the
increased intertwining of the data
industry with the finance industry or
the so-called defense industry
we are all familiar with the fact that
data extracting and data-driven
algorithms increasingly regulate the
temporal affective and inter-subjective
modalities of everyday life
and we are all familiar with how this
regulation along with the sometimes
top but sometimes legitimate concerns of
how ai may change the very definition of
the human as well as life itself is
increasingly not only of ethical but
existential concern
indeed there are good reasons why we are
experiencing what i would call an
ethical demand made by this
data-centric situation we now find
ourselves in
unfortunately at least in my view the
response to this ethical demand by most
data-centric practitioners and ethicists
is overwhelmingly framed in terms of
principles guidelines rules and
ultimately law and policy
this response has taken various forms
some for example have called for
increased ethical policing of data
science research which might take the
form of institutional review board
oversight
others consider it vital that data
scientists themselves receive some form
of ethical training to help combat for
example blindness to both their own and
structural biases that might enframe
their work or to help combat what is now
seen as the widespread transgressions of
data centric industries
finally some have argued that
data-centric technologies themselves
such as artificial intelligence must be
built with ethical capacities to help
guide their inevitable shaping of human
worlds
these are all reasonable and perhaps
even necessary responses
unfortunately however and true to the
instrumentalist reasoning that guides so
many data centric practitioners
ethics in each of these various forms
tends to be conceived in terms of what i
call either the checklist or rule book
approach to ethics
what i call the checklist approach
considers a practice ethical if and only
if certain predefined principles can be
checked off a pre-established list of
such principles does a certain
algorithmic practice respect the
principle of privacy yes good
check
ethical
that in essence is the principle based
or checklist approach to ethics in
action
similarly the rule book approach
considers a practice ethical if and only
if pre-articulated rules are followed
have you guarded against the
re-identification of your data
yes good rule followed ethical that in
essence is the rule-based or rule book
approach to ethics in action
while these two approaches may be useful
in certain institutional or bureaucratic
contexts for protection against
litigation or ethical research
compliance for example i argue they have
nothing to do with ethics as a human
practice and the cultivated
sensibilities necessary to be and become
an ethical person
therefore while the checklist and rule
book approaches may be useful for
example in the very narrow concern of
irb research approval or the prevention
of litigation it is the wrong road to
take if one were interested in for
example developing ethical persons who
are also data scientists
or as i will focus on in the rest of
this talk developing ethical data center
technologies such as artificial
intelligence
in order to clarify this i will take a
brief detour to consider an early and
important critique of artificial
intelligence
in 1965 the phenomenologist hubert
dreyfus published a critical essay
entitled alchemy and artificial
intelligence which was later expanded
into the book what computers can't do
in short dreyfus was critical of the
then dominant approach in artificial
intelligence research that assumed that
human intelligence is a matter of the
mental representation of facts and the
abstraction and interiorization of rules
and as such researchers assumed that
artificial intelligence could be
achieved through programmed rules and
the representation of facts
this is the symbolic information
processing model of a.i or symbolic a.i
dreifus predicted rightly it now seems
that such an approach would fail as it
began from the faulty cartesian
assumption of representationalism
in contrast to this cartesian approach
to intelligence dreyfus argued for an
embodied and phenomenological approach
to intelligence
building on the work of both martin
heidegger and maurice marlo ponti dreif
is considered intelligence as primarily
a consequence of our embodied and
involved ongoing activity in situations
in the world
through which over time we come to
acquire not only background common sense
understanding or intelligence but also
all the interests feelings motivations
and bodily capacities that go to make a
human being
as such intelligence is a matter of an
acquired and skilled habit that is
continuously maintained and developed by
means of a kind of situationally
sensitive feedback loop in response to
ongoing and altering situations
such embodied intelligence stripis
argued could never be
represented by data structures made up
of facts and rules
as he went on to put it if the body
turns out to be indispensable for
intelligent behavior
then we shall have to ask whether the
body can be simulated on a heuristically
programmed digital computer
if not
then the project of artificial
intelligence is doomed from the start
at the time dreyfus's intervention was
contemptuously and publicly dismissed by
most in the artificial intelligence
community
but privately many took it seriously and
considered how to adopt his insights
today things have changed
it seems rather obvious that the
contemporary successes of data centric
machine learning are at least in part a
matter of these new technologies
mimicking in some ways the
phenomenological approach to
intelligence that dreyfus argued for
in his updated version of the book what
computers still can't do
dreyfus acknowledges that data centric
ai and he particularly focuses on neural
networks has made some progress in this
direction and more recently he seems to
have accepted that neural networks have
to a great extent satisfy the
requirements of this phenomenological
approach to intelligence
bounded on a kind of feedback adjustment
between mind and world
importantly however dreyfus argues that
the problem of generalization a key
element for intelligence cannot be
solved without
cannot be solved with a disembodied
neural network though it does indicate
that a neural net robot with a body may
be able to solve this problem
for now however i will set this aside
for the extent to which dreyfus is
correct in his analysis or prediction is
beyond the scope of this talk
what you may ask does this have to do
with ethics
and what follows i would like to begin
to convince you that contemporary
concerns with developing ethical data
center technology should make a similar
shift in approach to a phenomenological
and relational notion of ethics
the first point to make is this
the checklist and rule book approaches
to ethics those approaches that speak in
terms of principles guidelines and rules
are analogous to the symbolic ai
approach to intelligence of programming
rules and representing facts
just as the ai community has learned
hopefully at least that intelligence and
practice is not a matter of symbolic
representation
so too it must learn that ethics and
practice is not a matter of following
rules or adhering to principles
to put it bluntly
ethics cannot be pre-programmed as a set
of rules or as a list of principles
this approach outside of a few
institutional and bureaucratic concerns
is a dead end
how then can we conceive of ethics in a
phenomenological and relational manner
to begin to answer this in the next
section i will articulate in broad
strokes what i call relational ethics
before in the final section turning to a
specific example of the ethical failure
of a data centric technology to
illustrate the importance of relational
ethics not only for the future of such
technologies but for social life as such
for the next several minutes i will
indulge in a bit of philosophizing so i
ask your patients
i hope though that it will prove helpful
as we move forward
perhaps the most fundamental of all
ethical questions is to ask how is it
between us
such a seemingly simple question is
immediately differentiable for more
commonly asked ethical questions such as
what is the good or did she act rightly
and in this differentiation its
radicality is revealed
when we ask what is the good or did she
act rightly there is an assumption built
into these questions that there is a the
good
the wetness of which we can we can query
or an exact rightness that can come to
modify precisely a particular act
when we ask these questions we assumed
the prior existence of the good or the
right already there as the object or the
measure in reference to which the
questions could be answered definitively
oftentimes the good or the right are
articulated in terms of rules principles
guidelines and laws the
pre-establishment of which stand
available as that against which we can
measure our ethical adequacy
is it possible to conceive of ethics
without the good or the right always
already there to measure up to
the standard by which any possible
ethics is judged
in the rest of this section i will
respond to this question in the
affirmative and begin to offer in broad
strokes an outline for what i call
relational ethics as that which offers a
response to the query of how it is
between us
the work of the philosopher immanuel
lebinos is vital here
in contrast to all of those ethical
theories that make the ontological
assumption that human subjects exist as
ethical subjects with some sort of a
priori built-in capacity to act
ethically
for example to be rule followers or
moral calculators or autonomous law
givers and adherents
lebinos argues that the ethical subject
is constituted through what he calls the
other
what does this mean
allow me to oversimplify
the other always exceeds any idea that i
may have of that other
for example in terms of what and who the
other is
what the other desires or even how i
should act with and toward the other
and loving us names this phenomenon of
the excess of the other infinity
because i and the other are always
intertwined in this infinite
relationality
as an ethical subject i must give myself
over or open myself to the unknowable
and incomprehensible difference that is
the other
therefore and in contrast to reducing
the other to comprehensibility
through a proceduralist act i have what
levines calls infinite responsibility to
the other
perhaps more appropriately rendered i
must respond to the call or demand of
the other
or alternatively i must attune to the
other
momentarily i will return to this
concept of responsivity and show how
lebinos considers the form of
conversation as the structure of this
attuned response
for lebanon's not only the possibility
of ethics but the very possibility that
i become an ethical subject begins with
the other
this formal structure of the condition
of possibility for ethics and the
ethical subject is what lebanese calls
transcendence
this notion of transcendence does not
establish a radical dichotomy between
ordinary everyday life and some realm
beyond
and it does not necessitate religion or
some other sphere of values
neither it should be noted does lebanon
transcendence indicate an imminent urge
to transcend any given option toward its
presumably better state or alternative
rather it simply expresses the
relational structure of ordinary
everyday existence
or as lebinos puts it the ecstatic
relationality of transcendence
delineates the structure of exteriority
and thus makes possible the pluralism of
society
perhaps the ordinariness of relation of
this relationality is best revealed in
lebanon's insistence that it begins in
the bodily materiality of the face of
the other
confronted by the enigma of the face of
the other
i must respond
i must attune
when this attunement does not occur in a
smooth fashion the enigma of the other
makes an ethical demand on me the
experience of which is what i have
called a moral breakdown
far from the mischaracterization of the
rupturing of the everyday made by those
who have critiqued this concept of moral
breakdown
the experience of a moral breakdown is
in fact more intensely felt and
considered relational intertwining with
others
and this relationality is more intensely
felt and considered in the moment of
breakdown precisely because the demand
of the other has explicitly called me to
ethically attune
in the next section i will consider more
closely how this attunement as empathic
attunement is the very condition of
possibility for ethics
despite the significance of this
relational structure for considering
ethics i have argued elsewhere that the
asymmetry that lebanon posits falls
short of the kind of mutuality of beings
some of us might prefer to consider
if for loving us the other is separated
from me by what he calls an infinite
curvature of intersubjectivity
then my task is to conceive of this
asymmetrical relation in more mutual
terms without reducing this mutuality to
a totalized co-relational
pseudo-relation
that is our question might be posed as
this
how to maintain the enigma of the other
and the asymmetrical relation this
entails while at the same time
recognizing that the other must also
relate to me as an enigmatic other
put another way
how can we conceive mutuality without
reducing this relation to a totality of
the same
i will begin to address these questions
by turning to what i call between
how is it between us
in contrast to asking the ah priority
question indicated by the what or did
a question that begins with the
assumption that ethics is an
accomplishment of a telos or acting
according to a predefined measure
to ask how
is to ask about an ongoing process
imminent to situations within which we
find ourselves
to ask how is to understand ethics as
ongoing attunement
who attunes
us
in contrast to the individual who aims
for the good or attempts to act rightly
and in contrast to a we that is a
totalized or categorized plurality
the us that attunes is the
non-categorizable plurality of singular
beings that are neither individuals nor
merely a part of a collective but unique
instances of being relational
put in lebanosian terms
the non-categorizable us is indicative
of a relational ontology that entails
that the other is always infinitely
other to me
as well as other possible others
how is it between us
this ongoing attunement imminent to
worlds and situations is indicative of
the ecstatic revelationality that gives
way to us
the place of this giving way i will name
between
but do so with the caveat that this
between that is relationality neither
can be objectified thing like
nor spatialized through this nomination
and yet this between the relationality
emerges
how
phenomenological analysis would disclose
multiple responses to this question
but given
the limitations of this talk today
as well as its clear resonance with many
ethical concerns raised by data-centric
technologies i will focus on one
possible response and that is language
the phenomenological hermeneutic
conception of language is helpful here
a good starting point for understanding
an important version of this is martin
heidegger's claim that language is the
house of being
what could such an enigmatic phrase mean
when he wrote this he immediately
followed it with this quote in it in its
home man dwells
humans dwell on language and do so as
existing
for heidegger as it is for much of this
tradition
to exist is to be ecstatic
always to be outside oneself intertwined
with other ecstatic beings human and
non-human alike
for humans
language is one of the primary
entanglements of this relationality
thus it is to a great extent through
language that humans are pulled beyond
themselves to dwell in between with
others
notice
this phenomenon is a pulling and not a
projecting
unlike those conceptions of language
that begin with a view of language
grounded in a prior and already
established set of criteria or grammar
that is projected out from the
individual speaker
a phenomenological view of language sees
language as a primary effective force
emanating from between us
that pulls and places demands on us to
respond
the many full responses which manifest
more as listening than speaking enliven
the between by means of their
distinction
thus in contrast to the projection of an
assumed shared criteria or grammar
projection that lebanon's considered to
be an act of violence
the distinctive and manifold responses
to the call of language give way to a
between characterized above all by
difference
a difference that is to which attunement
is ongoing
this is simply another way of describing
ethics
hider can heidegger contrasted this view
of language with more common conceptions
of language which as he put it is the
notion that language is the expression
produced by humans of their feelings and
the worldview that guides them
as he went on to claim this is a notion
of language from which we must become
liberated
this is the notion that assumes not only
that language is structured by a set of
shared criteria and grammar but also can
express a shared meaning
elsewhere i have argued against the
anthropological focus on shared meaning
and have tried to make the case that at
least in ethical encounters although i
presume this is indeed the case with
most encounters
language does not express shared meaning
but rather acts as what i call a bridge
of being
that is to say
ethics is ongoing attunement is not
about adhering to a pre-established
criteria or grammar and neither is it
about finding the spot of shared meaning
rather the extent that language is a
modality of ethical attunement it is
that call that demand
that pull
that allows the possibility to dwell
once again again with others in the
world between
us language as a modality of ethics then
calls us
places a demand on us to be with others
in the world in an attuned manner
letting us wrote of this phenomenon as a
conversation
for loving us language is the relation
between the same and the other
which is just a fancy philosophical way
of saying me and you whoever the me and
the you might be
ethically this relation takes the form
of conversation
here it is important to emphasize that
loving us is not arguing that the actual
act of conversation is ethics though at
times it may be
but rather that the form of conversation
can be understood as the formal
structure of ethics
what does this mean
in conversation lavinos writes we become
astonished
through conversation with the other
the other through conversation the other
is revealed in her strangeness to me
i can never know prior to the other
speaking what she will say
and as such i must listen and then
respond
but i cannot respond with a projection
my response cannot be a claim of knowing
the other and neither can it be a taking
over the conversational relation with
the claim that for example ah yes the
same thing happened to me
because the same thing never happens
such a claim is not a continuance of
open conversation but rather shuts it
down through the colonization of the
other by me
in conversation the other is revealed is
not the same which means that she cannot
be thematized through a projection of a
priory criteria or grammar or the claim
of a shared experience or the fitting
into some preconceived principle or rule
rather to be in conversation is to let
the other be and then attune
as such relational ethics encounters the
alternative the other through a tuned
letting b
that preserves the between of
differences
if as the anthropological linguist
eleanor oaks has written ordinary
enactments of language are modes of
experiencing the world
this can only be so because worlds and
situations are already partly
constituted through language
constituted not as i've been trying to
argue
as worlds and situations of a projected
shared meaning or a shared form of life
but rather as the between that pulls us
together in our differences in the
modalities of concern and
care
how is it between us
this is perhaps the most fundamental of
all ethical questions
because as humans we can only live
together in worlds and situations as
intertwined in a between that is all we
can ever share
it is for this reason that the
philosopher hannah arndt argued that we
are concerned and cared for the between
because we have an interest in its being
for the between is essential to the
human condition
we are concerned and care in our
interest
in our interest that is in our being
between as being relational
if in 1958 hana aren't could limit the
between to the human condition
in the 21st century that is no longer
possible
today such phenomena is climate change
and the colonization of everyday life by
data-centric technologies has made it
abundantly clear that the between is
essential to the existential condition
the between can no longer be limited to
between you and me
but must be the between of existence
and yet the manner in which the human
responds to the call of this existential
between will be decisive
do we continue to project our already
established rules and principles onto
the between
or do we let be and attune
if how is it between us is the most
fundamental question
then how we respond to it must be the
most fundamental of ethical as well as
existential replies
i have just articulated in broad strokes
a relational ethics that begins from the
fact that humans are primarily beings
who are relationally intertwined with
others in specific situations
and that what counts as ethics in our
everyday lives is not a matter of
adhering to a checklist of principles or
following a rule book but rather
responding and attuning to situationally
unique demands placed upon us in the
ongoing vicissitudes of life
in this sense ethics is not a matter of
deciding between a number of
predetermined options but rather in each
instance entails a singular response to
this situation now
such a response takes the form of an
attunement not only to the singularity
of the situation
but to the singularity of the other or
others there with you and to do so in
the modality of letting be and care
in the rest of my talk i will illustrate
the importance of this notion of
relational ethics for considering the
possibility of ethical and data centric
technologies
and most importantly their relational
intertwining in our everyday lives
consider the tragic case of mark
hemmings as recounted by john janey
lippeld in his book we are data
this is a quote from the book
it's 2013
and mark hemmings a 41 year old british
disabled man dials the number for
emergency services in the uk
999
an operator answers
and hemmings immediately makes his
condition known
my stomach is an agony duck i've got
lumps in my stomach
the operator responds with the first of
many inquiries
have you got any other symptoms
having replies i'm in agony sweating a
lot feeling weak
going on mostly all day
the operator asks more questions
have you had any diarrhea or vomiting
have you ever been diagnosed with an
aortic aneurysm or marfan syndrome have
you got any crushing or aching pain in
your upper abdomen
through the agony hemings diligently
puts
hemings diligently but excruciatingly
answers them all
he requests in the ambulance three
separate times
he also explains his pain
in description and accompanying tone as
agonizing a heartbreaking seven times
at the end of the call the operator
concludes from what you've told me you
don't require an emergency ambulance but
we will get somebody to call you back
90 minutes later a general practitioner
did call mr hemmings and recognize that
he needed to be seen immediately
still he refused to make a house call
and told mr hemmings to take an
ambulance instead
mr hemings told the gp that he had been
refused an ambulance
nevertheless and not taking this
important information into account the
gp still insisted that mr hemmings come
into the hospital and made an
appointment for him
when mr hemmings did not show for the
appointment his records were marked as
did not attend
two days later mr hemmings was
discovered by an in-house healthcare
worker unconscious in his home
and died minutes after having been
rushed to the hospital
mr hemmings died of a heart attack
brought on by gallstones blocking his
pancreatic duct
a routine operation would have saved his
life if he had been correctly diagnosed
and brought to the hospital
although the official cause of death was
heart attack
it is perhaps more accurate to say that
the tragic case of mr hemings is one of
death by algorithm
but the questions asked by the operator
were not her own
nor were they read from some template
but rather came directly from an
algorithmic triage system
the human operator simply acted as the
mouthpiece the voice of the algorithm
what can we learn from this tragic case
the most obvious takeaway is that an
ethical relation is not simply a matter
of input and output
although relational ethics is as i
argued in the previous section an
ongoing process of responsibility or
attunement is not simply a feedback
mechanism
mr hemmings provided all of the input he
was asked to but the output was not
ethically adequate to his situation
neither obviously was it medically
adequate but i will set aside that
disturbing fact
i should note that almost certainly a
linear algorithmic triage system was
used in this case which has an essential
task ensuring that certain rules are
followed
thus it would be inappropriate to expect
that it could attune to the singularity
of mr heming's ethical demand for care
as no delineated rules ethical or
otherwise could allow for attunement
input of this nature is simply illegible
to such an algorithmic system
some argue that a non-linear triage
system based on machine learning and
other artificial intelligence elements
would have the capacity to respond to
the singularity of individual medical
needs
this may be so
and yet this does not entail that such a
system would be any better responding to
the singularity of ethical demands
for ethical demands are not a matter of
providing more data and ethical
responses are not a matter of adjusting
parameters to increase data
let's be clear the ethical demand made
by mr hemmings in his 999 call was not
for the most part articulated through
his factual description of his
symptoms
but rather by means of his interjected
affective utterances sounds and tone
that infuse his answers to the
algorithmic questions mr hemmings did
not simply provide facts but more
importantly was making an ethical demand
on
another mr hemming's ethical demand is
not made in his description of his bowel
movements
but rather when he several times says
i'm in agony or asks if he could have an
ambulance
and speaks the entire time in an
agonizing tone with interspersed sounds
that indicate severe pain suffering and
the vulnerable need for care
in other words mr heming's ethical
demand is not made through the
articulation of facts read as data that
may or may not fit the measurable type
of deserving emergency treatment
rather his ethical demand is made as an
affective force
and as such the other to whom this
demand is made must be able to recognize
it as such and respond as called
such recognition and response are a
matter of what the anthropologist jason
troupe calls empathic attunement
and not simply a matter of input output
adjustments
for troop empathic attunement is that
human capacity that allows one to
imagine what the experience of another
could be like
such empathic attunement is a relational
matter in that not only does the other
participate in my empathic achievement
with her but she is simultaneously
attuning with me an attunement that i
too
in
we might describe this as reciprocal
attunement
in this sense empathic attunement and
the imaginative process it entails
allows for the essential intertwining of
being human together
in other words
empathic attunement is essential not
just to ethics but the sociality as such
this is a key insight from the
phenomenological tradition and the way
in which empathy has been articulated
within it
thus for example the phenomenologist dan
sahabi has written that empathy is the
term of choice for phenomenologists for
the experience of foreign consciousness
it is a distinctive form of other
directed intentionality
distinct from both self-awareness and
ordinary object intentionality which
allows foreign experiences to disclose
themselves as foreign rather than his
own
it is important here to note that
empathy is that which allows difference
in alterity to emerge or become
disclosed it is that which allows for
our recognition of the infinite
singularity of all others
rather than collapsing the other into a
projection of myself
indeed the philosopher edith stein was
quite clear that
empathy is a sui generous form of
intentionality directed at the other as
absolutely other
in this way empathic attunement is that
which allows for the asymmetrical and
infinite relationality between oneself
and another that i described in the last
section
and as the essence of relational ethics
thus as a sue daenerys other directed
intentionality
empathy could be considered the very
condition of possibility for ethics
now i'd like to take up this concept of
empathic attunement in a radically
relational manner
thus by empathic attunement i do not
intend the intersubjective coming to be
connected of two self-same
individualized subjects standing over
and against one another as this
phenomenological articulation of empathy
could be but i think would be mistakenly
read
rather by empathic attunement i mean
becoming attuned to always already
having been intertwined with other
beings
through the ecstatic relationalities we
essentially are
thus one does not have empathy for
another over against the self
but rather empathic attunement is the
attuned relationality
that constitutes what comes to be
derivatively experienced as for example
a you and an i
that is and as i have already described
empathic attunement is that which allows
for difference
empathic attunement then is the coming
into awareness of our essential
relational being as differentiated
ecstatic relationality
empathic imagination is the coming into
awareness by means of this attunement of
what it might be like as an other within
this relationality of being
empathic attunement and imagination
conceived in this radically relational
manner is essential to relational ethics
for indicates that ethics is not simply
a relational response of an input output
adjustment based on facts
but in attunement to the affective and
differential relationality of
intertwined existence
similar to the way in which the
philosopher edmund husserl argued that
we always have a sense of the beingness
that which we perceive as a result of
what he called a categorial intuition
that is infused in our relational
consciousness of any particular object
so too i suggest our attuned relational
being is infused with an empathic
intuition that provides the very
possibility for ethics
to put it simply
without the capacity for empathic
attunement ethics is not possible
mr hemmings in his own way knew this
well
he needed medical attention and sought
it in the only way he could
because this was likely not the first
time he had dealt with the overly
bureaucratic medical system of the uk
he seemed to understand that while he
needed to meet the strict bureaucratic
standards necessary to be offered care
he should also add an ethical appeal or
demand to help persuade the operator to
send an ambulance
if the bureaucracy fails to recognize
him perhaps the human would he may have
thought
unfortunately for mr hemmings he was not
speaking with another human but rather
the human articulation of an algorithmic
system
as such an ethical demand could not be
made by mr hemmings because empathic
attunement was impossible
the much hyped human in the loop of
normative data ethicists was rendered in
human by being reduced to nothing more
than the auditory supplement of the
algorithmic system
perhaps we could conceive of the
operator as an anthropo board
for as the human in the loop she simply
became part of an input output factual
feedback system
and not the guarantor of an ethical
outcome as normative data ethicists
would hope
with the human in the loop rendered
inhuman
mr hemmings could not make an ethical
demand because there is no other being
with whom he could ethically and
empathically attune
and he could and who could attune with
him and return
if as dan sahabi has written i am
pathetically attuned to the other as a
spender of orientation
as a perspective on the world
and as a result my relation to the world
will change since the other will always
be given to me in a situation or
meaningful context which points back to
the other as a new center of reference
the meaning of the world has for the
other affects the meaning it has for me
then this simply cannot happen with data
centric technologies
current attempts to build what is called
emotional ai for example
will i suspect ultimately failed to live
up to any expectation from empathic
attunement
this is so because such attempts are
founded on the assumption that data such
as varying heart rate the flutter of a
micro facial expression
the sudden rise in skin conductance can
serve as measurable and machine readable
signs of affect
as long as data-centric technologies can
only recognize humans as just another
object in the world that is a source of
data extraction
then it will never be able to recognize
a human as a perspective on the world
that is above all else a dependently
relational being
without such recognition recognition
that emerges in excess of any amount of
available data ethical attunement is
impossible
of course
of course data centric technologies
can't do this one might proclaim an
exasperation
but what of that operator doesn't she
have a moral obligation to step in and
override the system
doesn't she have any principles
it would be too easy and i believe naive
to level moral condemnation on the
operator
for she like mr hemmings was simply
caught up in a larger neoliberal
bureaucratic assemblage that values
efficiency in the bottom line over care
for others be they human or otherwise
and data centric technologies are just
the latest tools for achieving these
values
when efficiency and profit are the
primary values an instrumental reason is
the primary means of achieving them
then all of those caught up within the
various manifestations of this
assemblage are too often rendered
incapable of the most basic human
capacities for ethically attuning with
others
in this sense algorithmic artificial
intelligent and other data centric
technologies are the latest dream tool
of neoliberal bureaucratic assemblages
of control and order that render ethics
nearly impossible
as a result if not unlike the man
standing before the law in kafka's
parable
mr hemmings received no response
ethically or medically as you pleaded
for both before the cold logic of the
algorithm
and then he died
according to the diagnostic and
statistical manual of mental disorders
fifth edition
anti-social personality disorder is
characterized by among other things a
lack of empathy for others often times
exhibited in the process of
accomplishing an aim or desired outcome
by almost any means and without concern
for how the outcome affects others
this disorder is more colloquially known
as sociopathy or psychopathing
it may also be the best description of
the algorithmic triage system described
in the previous section and perhaps all
data-centric technologies in general
we should recall that the aim of the of
two of the participants in turing's
famous imitation game that is the man in
the machine
was to deceive the interrogator
the aim of the third participant the
woman was to help the interrogator
putting aside the revealing gender
assumptions and dynamics that set the
context of this game
we might like to note that thinking and
remember the question that guides the
imitation game is can machines think
is more or less equated with the ability
to deceive another by means of
strategic lying and deception and
without any concern for the other and
how he or she may feel about this
what turing identifies as thinking
psychology identifies as psychopaths
today the thinking machines that turing
envisioned exist and are increasingly
folded into the texture of our everyday
lives such that when we ask how is it
between us
we oftentimes must count some form of
data center technology is right there
with us if not disruptively between us
one response to this of course is to
continue the head-in-the-stand approach
that has characterized much of the last
decade or so as these technologies have
slowly and now rapidly become a part of
our worlds
but in doing so we must accept that we
will surely see more and more tragic
cases like that of mr hemmings
another response would be that of the
normative ethicists and their principles
and guidelines who seem to think that
ethics is little more than adhering to
the checklist or the rulebook or perhaps
even a calculation
this approach is appealing to
data-centric practitioners because it
matches well their instrumental view of
the world
ethics in this view is just another
pre-programmable
pre-programmable parameter to solve a
predefined problem
unfortunately ethical demands and the
responses they call for can never be
pre-known or predetermined
for ethics to be ethics there cannot be
any predetermined mode of action and
outcome
ethics is not a program
it is a situationally attuned struggle
to decide despite the undecidability of
the moment
as such ethical demands and responses
can only be recognized as they emerge in
situ and responded to in the best
possible manner which in many cases is
simply a good enough manner as the
singular demand of this situation calls
i've been trying to show that because
data center technologies are and will
increasingly become a significant aspect
of our worlds we need to recognize that
when we ask how it is between us
how we reply will be significantly
determined by the way these technologies
respond to us there in the between of
our everyday worlds
this is what i urge data scientists and
other so-called innovators and builders
of data-centric technologies to realize
just as artificial intelligence
benefited greatly from the
phenomenological critiques leveled
against it by hubert dreifus and others
so too only phenomenological and
relational ethics can both adequately
describe the responsivity of ethics as
well as offer a telos as it were for
which that responsibility aims
we may one day discover that it is
impossible to build data centric
technologies such as artificial
intelligence that are capable of
empathic and ethical attunement
but if we don't try and try in ways that
go beyond reading the human as a source
of data extraction then i'm afraid that
our worlds will increasingly be
populated by psychopathic machines
thank you
jared thank you that was fantastic
i have several questions as i was
listening to you talk and you made the
comment of language is the house of
being and i thought a little bit about
language and where language kind of fits
into our biomedical
research enterprise and probably
one of the most place most important
places where it comes in in the research
enterprise
is in the relational ethics which
involve informed consent between a
researcher or an investigator and a
research subject and very often
researchers refer to themselves in the
we we are doing this research we're very
august very highly accomplished people
we are our own unitary group whereas
them the research subjects are those
people who are going to come in and do
our experiments and and basically be
data providers for us
flipping that around the research
subjects may have motivations for
wanting to participate in that
experiment they may have expectations
about what they're going to get out of
it if anything likewise for the
investigators and it's in that in
between that there is some degree of
empathic
um
attunement and i was just kind of
curious about
how do we kind of overcome the tendency
to view informed consent and the ethics
involved with it as just kind of being
pro-forma
checklist-y kind of stuff how can we
actually take that more seriously and
understand that there's an attunement
that we need to achieve with our
research subjects so that we can one
make them full participants in our
research and provide us with the kind of
data we can you know use effectively
does that make sense i hope so
yeah i think so uh thanks jack
so that question's a little bit
different from what i was trying to
argue in terms of
kind of how we build ethics into
machines as it were so i'm going to get
to that in a minute
but but that but what you ask is
certainly
important and so
so on the one hand i want to say that
kind of the very model of informed
consent and
uh that often as part of for example on
irb institutional review board um
research
approved research um in a sense this
kind of goes against
or is counter to
or outside of what i've been trying to
argue for in the sense that it is
um at least in my experience and as an
anthropologist who's done quite a bit of
field research um
i've always had to have
that research pre-approved by irb but
it's
the irb model is kind of this
this kind of as i put it in the talk
this projection this this this
predetermined preconceived projection of
of what the relationship
already will be and and the consensus
may be informed in the sense that the
the research participant
is now made aware of what
how the research will unfold and they
will be a part of it but
in most cases they have very little say
on how that research unfolds they just
kind of as it were consent to be folded
into it right um to use the fancy
language that i used a bit in the talk
it's it's a projection of the same onto
the other it's not it's not a kind of
listening and letting be to the other
that that i respond to as a researcher
and then kind of adjust
along the way
um
does that make any sense so yeah
i think the sorry but i think the goal
here would be changing the very idea of
what an informed consent process would
look like such that it is a
more
mutual kind of
um
to use a kind of language i would
normally not use a kind of negotiation
but um but that might be in maybe the
easiest quickest way to put it that
that's that's interesting you also
brought up
the experience of mr hemings and you
made the comments of
death by algorithm and any of us of
if you have lived long enough you start
to run into
problems with relatives or loved ones
who are admitted to hospital and the
nurse comes in and she you know takes a
blood pressure and asks you know what's
your pain level out of ten you know and
the person says you know eight or nine
and then they walk the nurse walks out
of the room and you're like what was the
point of that and
somebody who has that whether it's in it
from a computer or it's just how people
are trained to follow an algorithm this
is what you do
i mean is this sort of the human
equivalent of an ai system being trained
to recognize images of dogs but being
presented with the image of a bird and
not really knowing how to change out of
the algorithm is that
fair
yeah and i think that's kind of the
let's say the limitation of this example
that i gave is that i recognize that
that a lot of um
practice in in medical settings like
like the one you just gave um
are in some ways algorithmic already
even if it's not through a computer
right um so
um so this is kind of a broader
critical intervention on on
health and medical contexts where
again there's needs to be get out of
this um algorithmic approach whether
that's through a computer or a template
or just um the training that that that
uh
professionals go through um and you know
and this is
i'm certainly far from the first person
to to to talk about this but this
something that
uh seems increasingly important now that
um
that um
these this algorithmic approach is is is
incredibly is is even further out of the
hands of a human
than say just kind of that that that
template that's back at the nurse's
station or whatever you know
if you know what i mean yeah i mean i'm
just thinking about how we try to
emulate
those kind of interactions in a computer
system you know we're presented with an
ipad and you go through and you check
some boxes and you know it's essentially
doing what a nurse or you know medical
professional might have done um and
they're following a routine an algorithm
a recipe and you know the recipe
you know does if you if you deviate from
the recipe they
isn't sure what to do with that
information which brings me to my last
question
which is can any machine or algorithm or
you know pile of computer code
which as you claim may be psychopathic
ever pass a turing test if empathic
attunement is a criteria
well
assuming that i understand the question
and the turing test correctly
then i i would say that um
that
one that is able to
um exhibit a that's the right word um
have empathic attunements um would be
the
uh
would pass the turing test um you know
um with you know battery line colors
flying colors except the highest grade
precisely precise but that person if
that is if the question is precisely you
know like is this a human or a machine
i i think that it's precisely the
empathic attunement aspect that makes us
human and not the thinking aspect
yeah and that's what really struck me is
as we're developing algorithms and we
want them
almost in some instances to behave as if
they're human this empathic attunement
adjusting to the point of view of
another having a theory of mind if you
will for what the other
maybe
what their motivations and their
expectations are
without that a computer is just going to
be another another psychopath that we
have to contend with
in a world full of them
anyway
uh jared thank you so very much this was
uh very thought provoking um it has a
lot of relevance to the topic of
how we're thinking about ai applications
what that really means uh as
you know as we
embed this into health related research
health related practice um in medicine
and in our understanding of how we're
going to
try and create
smart health systems and ai driven
methodologies i really appreciate you
taking the time to chat with us today
this was super fun thank you so much
thank you jack it was really my pleasure
everybody have a wonderful